>>> NEW TONIGHT, SARAH PALIN HAS
FAILED AT HER MOST RECENT
ATTEMPT AT A POLITICAL COMEBACK.
SHE LOST THE SPECIAL ELECTION
FOR VACANT HOUSE SEAT IN ALASKA.
THAT SEAT IS FLIPPING TO A
DEMOCRAT FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE 1972.
HERE TO DISCUSS, FORMER U.S.
REPRESENTATIVE ABBY FINK NOWER
AND ERROL LEWIS AND S.E. CUP.
S.E., LET ME START WITH YOU,
SARAH PALIN, HUGE NAME
RECOGNITION.
THAT WAS THE PLAY.
SHE HAD THE NAME RECOGNITION.
DIDN'T WIN.
>> WELL, I THINK ERROL AND I
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT, FELLOW
DAILY NEWS ALUM.
I'VE HAD A DAILY NEWS COLUMN FOR
12 YEARS, IN PART BECAUSE THE
FIRST COLUMN I WROTE WAS ABOUT
SARAH PALIN -- IS WHAT PEOPLE
THOUGHT HER NAME WAS.
>> WE WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE PRONUNCIATION.
>> I LIKED HER STORY.
I THOUGHT AS MUCH AS HE HURT
JOHN McCAIN, SHE ALSO HELPED
JOHN McCAIN.
SHE WENT ON TO BE FOX FAMOUS AND
SHE WANTED TO SORT OF FOLLOW
FAME.
AND I GET THAT SHE LOOKED AT
THIS LANDSCAPE WITH THE MARGE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENES AND THE
MATT BOEBERTS AND THOUGHT GREAT,
FINALLY A CHANCE TO BE FAMOUS
AND NOT HAVE TO GOVERN THAT
MUCH.
BUT I THINK ALASKANS WERE TURNED
OFF AND ABANDONED BY HER WHEN
SHE LEFT THE STATE IN SEARCH OF
MORE FAMOUS PASTURES.
I THINK THAT WAS THE RESULT.
>> IS THIS ABOUT SARAH PALIN
SPECIFICALLY?
THERE'S NO KIND OF LESSON THAT
REPUBLICANS CAN GLEAN FROM THIS
LOSS?
>> IF THEY WANTED TO TALK A
LESSON FROM IT, IT MIGHT WELL BE
THAT THE LOCAL LEADS -- IN THIS
CASE, ALASKA ONLY GETS ONE
REPRESENTATIVE.
THEY'VE GOT TO GET IT RIGHT.
THEY'VE GOT SALMON SHORTAGE,
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES JUST LIKE
EVERYWHERE ELSE.
AND IT SEEMS VOTERS DON'T WANT
TO THROW IT AWAY ON SOMEONE
THAT'S GOING TO GET UP AND DO
THE CELEBRITY THING.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR A CELEBRITY THERE.
THAT'S A LESSON REPUBLICANS
SHOULD TAKE TO HEART.
>> LET'S ALSO NOT SELL THE
DEMOCRATIC NOW WINNER SHORT
HERE.
I MEAN, FIRST NATIVE ALASKAN
EVER TO BE ELECTED.
I THINK THAT SAYS SOMETHING.
ALSO A DEMOCRAT HASN'T WON IN,
WHAT, 50 YEARS IN THAT SEAT?
I MEAN, THAT SAYS SOMETHING.
AND I THINK IT'S ANOTHER
INDICATOR THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
HOPE.
>> LET'S TURN TO DR. OZ ON
COMMENTS ON ABORTION.
WE'RE GOING TO PLAY FIRST WHAT
HE SAID IN MAY OF THIS YEAR.
THIS WAS DURING THE PRIMARY.
THEN WE'RE GOING TO PLAY
SOMETHING FROM AN INTERVIEW HE
IN 2019 WHERE HE TALKS ABOUT
HEART BEAT BILLS THAT WERE BEING
PASSED.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I DO BELIEVE LIFE STARTS AT
CONCEPTION, AND I SAID THAT
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND I STILL THINK CONCEPTION,
WHY DO YOU CARE WHAT AGE THE
HEART STARTS BEATING.
IT'S STILL MURDER IF YOU WERE TO
TERMINATE A CHILD WHETHER YOU'RE
HEART IS BEATING OR NOT.
>> ALABAMA AND ANTIABORTION LAWS
THEY'RE PASSING IN ALABAMA.
>> I'M REALLY WORRIED ABOUT IT.
THIS OTHER THING IS THIS THING
ABOUT HEART BEATING, THE
ELECTRICAL EXCHANGES AT SIX
WEEKS, BUT THE HEART'S NOT
BEATING.
IF YOU WERE TO SAY STARTING FROM
WHEN WE CAN HEAR THE HEART, WHEN
THE HEART'S REALLY DOING
SOMETHING, THAT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT.
THAT'S NOT SIX WEEKS THOUGH.
>> WHICH IS IT?
HOW CAN YOU BELIEVE BOTH OF
THOSE IN A SPAN OF THREE YEARS?
>> YOU CAN IF YOU'RE A
POLITICIAN AND YOU'RE RUNNING
NKS RIGHT?
IT'S A LITTLE UNSURPRISING,
ESPECIALLY DR. OZ.
HE'S GOT THIS SORT OF LABEL AS
FLIP FLOPPING AND NOT REALLY
BEING FROM PENNSYLVANIA AND
RUNNING ONE WAY IN A PRIMARY AND
ANOTHER NOW IN A GENERAL.
AND NOT ALL THAT SURPRISING.
WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
CANDIDATES, ESPECIALLY ON THE
ABORTION ISSUE, TRY TO MODERATE
IN A GENERAL ELECTION.
THAT HAPPENS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA, THEN BARACK
OBAMA, FAMOUSLY SHIFTED AFTER
DEFEATING HILLARY CLINTON IN A
PRIMARY, WENT MORE TO THE CENTER
ON ECONOMIC ISSUES.
AND IT REALLY ANGERED A LOT OF
FOLKS IN THE LEFT WINGS OF HIS
PARTY.
THE PROBLEM IS THIS IS A SUPER
IMPORTANT ISSUE THIS ELECTION
CYCLE.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY PAYING
ATTENTION ON BOTH SIDES TO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING.
>> YEAH, WE'RE SEEING THIS JUST
LIKE S.E. SAID ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HERE.
IN IOWA, FOR EXAMPLE, I WOULD
SAY IOWA 3 IS LITERALLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT FRONTLINE RACE IN THE
COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
PROTECT, THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
TRYING TO WIN.
AND YOU'VE GOT THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE WHO STOOD THERE, I
SUPPOSE, DURING THE PRIMARY WITH
HIS HAND UP IN THE AIR SAYING
THAT HE DOESN'T SUPPORT ANY
EXCEPTIONS FOR RAPE, INCEST,
LIFE OF THE MOTHER, ANYTHING.
AND YET, LIKE A WEEK AGO, WRITES
AN OP-ED FOR "THE DES MOINES
REGISTER" COMPLETELY CHANGING
HIS POINT.
BUT THAT IS AN AD RUN